head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
from Politico Elon Musk backs
Republicans ahead of midterms shared
power curbs the worst accesses of both
parties musk wrote in a tweet he wanted
to say that he's always been independent
leaning Democrat now he's saying it's
time to vote Republican to
independent-minded voters shared power
curves the worst excesses of both
parties therefore I recommend voting for
a republican Congress given that the
presidency is democratic musk wrote on
Twitter
all right I'll take it I guess he ain't
wrong yeah I mean I think I think that's
the way to go personally and I think a
lot of the states where we have
contentious elections
um you know like New York suddenly it
was very contentious we have Kathy hokel
who is just the worst I mean she's
terrible and we have Lee zeldin who has
the you know broad support of the Jewish
Community that's been facing increasing
anti-Semitism in the city
um and suddenly zeldin has pulled ahead
in the polls that's fascinating I don't
think we've had a republican governor in
New York City New York State uh since uh
Pataki yeah what was the last one that
was like 94. that was uh no 2000 I think
he was also a Bilderberg member uh
George Pataki oh really I had a
conversation with him it didn't go as as
good as I thought already uh but but the
argument that Elon Musk is making here
is essentially I was talking about this
a couple days ago on the show saying
specifically the best government is no
government when the government is
fighting each other that's the
government I want because then the
government isn't fighting you the
citizenry and the points he makes all
your money though well not if they're
not passing laws by by having of course
arguments about them and not agreeing
with them so they're spending less of
your money they're passing less laws
when there's of course a juggernaut
inside of the capital and all of them
are disagreeing on what they should be
doing but what we have going on right
now is we have a Congress that disagrees
with each other that doesn't get
anything done and so then we have a
president who just runs uh executive
orders from the Oval Office spending
trillions of dollars in so doing on all
kinds of random garbage yeah yeah I mean
I mean executive orders have been
normalized by the previous presidents
and it seems like every president is
doing it more and more and more yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean Trump had a bunch
of Executives well uh Obama had a ton he
had more than Bush and I think we also
have to counter and factor in the
Federal Reserve policies that truly do
matter when it comes to our money but
I'm not making the policy about even
just the money I'm talking about
government intervening in your life and
I think that's what Elon Musk is calling
for here at checks of balances so the
Republicans say no to the Democrats the
Democrats say no to the Republicans I'm
all for that yeah I think what we'll end
up seeing if we do have you know the Red
Wave is we're going to see all of these
investigations because Congress won't be
able to get any laws passed but they
will be able to dig into things and
figure out what's been going on agreed
yeah subpoena power Rand Paul I guess
it's gonna be on like the health
committee or something yeah and Marjory
Taylor Green's going to get some
committees back she wants to be on what
the oversight committee is that what she
said which one did she want to be on but
uh you know she's got McCarthy over a
barrel a little bit and he's gonna have
to put her on whatever she wants
and then maybe a couple years later
great two years later we won't have
we'll have new leadership maybe we'll
get more America First candidates in but
this is a start what's the best
government Owen give us that give us the
answer here I don't know I've had so
many conflicting opinions of this as
I've gotten older minimal I think the
challenge is with uh I think any any uh
a lot of these ideologies communism even
anarchism are are utopian they're
idealistic and humans are driven by
emotion one of the challenges with uh
the the marketplace of ideas argument
that we should let all the ideas compete
uh compete with each other which I
mostly agree with is that what we've
seen consistently from the left is
exploitation of emotion for power
and so when you put every idea in the
marketplace and one idea is two plus two
equals four
the left comes in and says you're a
white supremacist and you go huh and
then it makes people feel bad those
feelings drive them more than the facts
do so your argument only works insofar
as you're able to effectively
communicate when you have people who are
clearly not trying to communicate and
trying to deceive and destroy
well you get big problems so we can say
we want to be we want no government we
want to be libertarian we want to say
everybody can do their thing but then
evil people seek to exploit well it goes
even deeper too and you have censorship
so now you can't even fight back
effectively
um I feel like if you have free speech
openly and you can fight back I mean you
can make really really compelling
arguments I mean if there was a platform
where we could speak freely the things
that I the kind of content that I could
make would be off the chains but can't
do it right so that's one part another
thing too is that it's really really
sick and sociopathic when you see some
of the most important issues in the
world things like you know being against
white supremacy then being Twisted for
some kind of political agenda I mean
these are really really important issues
that then get twisted and it actually
devalues it right so if everybody's
being called these things it devalues it
for when there's a real instance of that
which is just one of the sickest things
that I've ever seen and it's one of
these things where then people are
afraid to even give their opinion
um because if you get painted with that
brush it's like it's kind of like
getting becoming radioactive yeah I'm
for Anarchy myself because Anarchy to me
represents decentralization and I think
most of our problems in our society are
plaguing from centralization and I think
the more we break up power the more we
allow individuals to decide for
themselves that is right for them I
think that's the pathway that's going to
help us but then maybe the real answer
is not Anarchy but to recognize that a
system will always the power will always
begin to coalesce and there needs to be
a mechanism to immediately shatter that
centralized power and then recognizing
that your decentralized system will
slowly start to centralize again
I I don't think we have in this country
the proper mechanisms for
re-establishing decentralization and
it's because power doesn't want to give
itself up so the Constitution has done a
really great job of holding back rapid
centralization but even now the
Constitution is Swiss cheese yeah and
things are really things are really
tightening up at a federal level you
even hear Biden talking about how if the
Democrats hold Congress they're going to
pass um they're going to federally
legalize abortion even though that's not
something that the populace as a whole
wants they're just going to do stuff
anyway and they've been and they I mean
when was the last time they declared war
yeah they don't do that they do Vietnam
they do instead though pass legislation
about not being discriminatory based on
people's hairstyles that's in New York
that's an actual law passed in New York
City yes where if you get caught
discriminating against someone's haircut
allegedly you have to pay what is it a
hundred fifty thousand dollars 125 000.
that's for accidental if it's a willful
uh discrimination it's 250. that's
insane that's too much government that's
too much but I'm pretty sure they put
that in at the federal level I'm pretty
sure that went through Congress I don't
remember hearing I remember hearing it
in New York City specifically yeah it
was definitely in New York City but
they're also going to put in put through
the thing the federal level where you
basically can't be a freelancer anymore
you know the the like ab5 in California
doing that the pro act New York's doing
that New York is doing that but also the
federal government is doing that I think
what yeah Biden has been pushing for
that for a while that's apocalyptic that
would that so so devastating plan
because it means that people are no
longer in control of their own work
product it means you can't you can't be
an independent you can't just be
yourself and hire yourself out and do
some work so ab5 those aren't familiar
it was this law they passed in
California that said something like it
was different per job but if you do a
certain number of jobs as an independent
contractor you're now an employee what
happened was instantly my favorite thing
Vox SB Nation fired all their
Freelancers they had to because they
couldn't do it and they couldn't be a
freelancer in California anymore and
also the companies that um the law was
designed to go after like uber and some
other ones got waivers right so they
didn't have to do it but here's the way
it works under this law and if with the
pro Act is that New York or that Federal
the pro act that would be Federal so
this is what that means let's say you
make birdhouses for a living
and then you go to a local shop and say
I'd like to sell you this birdhouse I
can't buy from you because if I buy too
many then you're an employee wait what
I'm just trying to sell you a birdhouse
well and then they have all the
regulations about different ways that
you have to treat your employees and you
have to give you know sick leave and
parental leave communism yeah and the
other thing too is like you're just a
person you want to work out of your
house you don't want to be beholden to
some company you don't want them to tell
you what to do and the next thing you
know you can't you know make yourself
I'm an employer based out of California
and I can tell you that once they
started bringing that stuff in we
actually decided just to shrink and then
when covet happened we decided to shrink
even more and we actually became a lot
more efficient and profitable I was the
kind of person where I just we usually
have around 100 employees and I did that
because I just like to hire people I
just want people to get paid and I like
making jobs but when they start messing
with you like that you're like you know
what forget it we're just going to
become more efficient and that's what we
did and now there's homeless people
everywhere because they're struggling to
function in the society yeah well vote
for more of it I guess tomorrow hey
here's your chance if you want to bring
it all down yeah but I'm not even
kidding many any of these far leftists
are like if you vote for them they will
keep burning it down I actually hit a
point where um because I run a seminars
company and they wouldn't let us do
seminars anymore during covid and I
decided just to travel around and just
hang out in the outdoors I skied every
major ski resort I went to almost every
National Park I just drove the country I
said I'm good I don't need to run some
big company
um we can run it more profitably without
all that stuff we just liked making jobs
but if they're saying that they're going
to mess with us like that what's the
incentive like how do I know they're not
going to lock down again I don't know
that so I don't care if they're going to
play those games like Atlas Shrug you
ever read Alice yeah I'm just like I'm
chill it's all good gotta leave Southern
California yeah I mean I am and they're
demoral I want to move to Wyoming
actually I want to ski but they're
demoralizing employers yeah it sucks
it's been horrible out there why why are
you still there yeah they're doing that
across La is pretty awesome it actually
is pretty awesome but not really it's
super duper awesome
come visit sometime I invite you guys I
live there you guys got to come crash me
no it's a lot of fun but I've lived
there for a couple years it's not
awesome you know well you gotta live in
the right place where'd you live I lived
in Koreatown I lived in Westwood and I
lived in North Hollywood okay well I
hope you'll come visit sometime I want
to show you around but okay just because
you lived in the right places
apparently had the wrong experience yeah
but the point the point being is that
Caruso might get in we're all hoping for
Rick Caruso we're all praying you're
still gonna happen Newsome and he's a
menace thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time